Film Courage: We posted a poll on
our Youtube community tab and the
question was do you trust film distributors
so the poll received about 8,000 or so votes
and 85 percent of those polled said they do not
trust distributors. Now, we didn't ask them in
what capacity they've dealt with them. Where do
you think this negative reputation stems from?
Glen Reynolds, Founder of Circus Road
Films: It all goes to the the failure rate
of films and I think that
some distributors oversell what will happen to
films in order to get them, not all but some do,
I think it goes to expectations of just getting
a distribution deal and thinking hey I'm done
it's going to make make money I think that's part
of it I think it's frustrating to have gatekeepers
to the public there's there there's so many things
coming out of a dollar before it gets to you
as the filmmaker because someone buys the film on
iTunes iTunes is taking 30 percent right that's 70
is going to your distributor your distributor
is taking 25 and costs so when they get by costs
then they're paying you at that point right so
there's there's a lot of international sales your
international sales company is taking 20 percent
they're putting it with a distributor overseas is
going to take their percentage that distributor
is putting on a digital platform that's gonna
put it and make money in Germany or wherever so
there's three steps before it gets gets to you
so if it were the case that and it is the
case that people could go and put film
you do have the ability to go put the
film on digital platforms yourself
so there are labs that have kind of aggregator
kind of call themselves aggregators although
I think the word aggregator is
kind of a strange word for it but
all they really do is facilitating placing
the film on Amazon iTunes google play etc
and there you're paying them the cost
of encoding the film for the platform
but they're not taking the percentage at all so
you're iTunes is taking 30 and you're getting 70
the reason why and now maybe
some films should do that because
they could just it's a small
film and they can push people to
watch on iTunes and then they get what they
they reap what they sew the reason people go to
distributors as opposed to doing it themselves is
distributors can get to more platforms than these
labs can there are some platforms that require
a pitch so to get a film on in demand Directv,
Dish etc you need someone to go and pitch the
movie to them and then when it comes out on iTunes
and Amazon cetera it's going to be the release
date is going to be the same for those platforms
in addition these distributors have relationships
with streaming companies like Netflix and Hulu
and HBO so once they have the film in the
transactional VOD world they're then going
to go try to make that sell if you go put your
film on iTunes you can't there's just no way
to get into Netflix at that point even I can't go
to Netflix I can go to Netflix originals division
as a producer rep but I can't go to them in a
distributor position of where it is after it's
been on transactional for a while so if we lived
in a world where all these platforms were open to
filmmakers going there that's what we would do
and I would I would become a marketing expert
instead I would help people with marketing and
just say hey let's just go put in these platforms
but there are gatekeepers to those platforms
where people have those relationships and that's
the reason we have to use them and then there are
some people that treat that space honorably and
are respectful of the fact they got lucky
enough to be in such a position to be the
gateway for other people's content and treat their
filmmakers well and explain everything to them and
try to do the best and then there are some that
really just take it and never call you back and
that's that's for I think it kind of goes back
to communication I think at the end of the day
there's just if if distributors did a better
job of communicating on the front end what's
going to happen what the what what's likely
what's realistically the a medium outcome
or the best outcome and in addition we're a little
bit more open as filmmakers came back to them
with questions about how it's going and explain
what why they were doing what they were doing I
think if they were better at that in general
that poll number would be a little bit better
although I think the the main reason for it
is just most films fail and and therefore who
we're gonna blame I'm not gonna blame my movie
my movie is perfect right like I it's my baby
and the person who adopted my baby is not
raising it properly and but but yeah I think
but that's hard that's hard for them to do it's
it's in the deal you're dealing with corporations
and distributors are not individuals and so
you've got the director of acquisitions the
director of sales the director of delivery the CFO
the accounting department and they all have their
own lanes of what they kind of deal with and as
the filmmaker like oh so who do I talk to about
the fact that this doesn't look right or I want
I don't Amazon my poster on Amazon looks a little
weird or whatever and sometimes it's hard
to navigate because not all companies have
a front person it's just like kind of the
the go-to for the client to say okay you got
this problem talk to this person I think part of
this is like economics like they just don't have
the bandwidth to have that many employees at the
end of the day and take the they they do the math
of like we need to take this number of films we
can make this amount of money and so we've got to
stretch our employees to do this number of jobs
and they're just not going to get royal treatment
like they want and then there's also the the
sort of thought of that filmmakers are artists
and their work is kind of never done so they're
probably tweaking the poster art maybe the log
line different things and then they're making all
these changes and submitting it and then you're
dealing with business people who don't have the
time maybe to to handhold all these subsequent
I mean I'm sure that probably happens a little
bit and then they feel like they're being ignored
and maybe in some cases they are being ignored and
others it's just their demands are so high yeah
yeah I don't know if I don't see a lot of people
still tinkering after the fact it's usually
the t it's usually the case that they have to at
some point they have to okay I'm done and let it
and let it go creatively at least in terms
of log line or trailer or things like that
I don't see a lot of people where
I see it breaking down is much more
in terms of like well what's happening you're
like are you trying to sell Netflix like I haven't
heard anything and most distributors just don't
care about communicating that they don't really
they feel like we're doing our job we're going to
pay you what you do but we don't need to explain
to you what we're saying to Netflix or when
we're going to talk to Netflix or or any of that
I just feel like distributors probably
don't feel like they have the time in a
day to talk to all their filmmakers about all the
intricacies of everything they do is my best guess
best guess from being on the outside looking in
a lot but never really being in at the same time
what type of accounting practices
should a filmmaker expect
when working with a distributor so overwhelmingly
most distributors offer quarterly accountings
and that's that's pretty standard to at
least get two or three years of quarterly
and then and then turns to biannual after that or
annual sometimes and that's when your most of your
revenue is gonna that's what it really counts
the most the frustrating thing with accounting
is that distributors are on accounting
terms as well with the platforms
so a lot of times people get their first quarter
statement and they're ready okay let's see how we
did and it's not there's not much there and that's
partly because when I go and buy a film on Amazon
Amazon keeps that money for 90 days before
it hits the bank account of your distributor
and so if it's March and I paid for it in march
it's not going to hit the distributor until
June and that's the second quarter so even though
someone paid for something in the first quarter
the streamer didn't get it until
the second quarter and so that's
when they're going to account for it usually
anywhere from 30 to 90 days after the quarter
so it takes a long time for stuff
to come in and that's frustrating
I wish it was more I wish it was unfortunately
that's what makes it hard to do anything in
social media to try and help the cause
because you can if you buy ads and stuff
for lots of products out there you can kind of
see what it does for you right and if you spend
ten thousand dollars on facebook ads you can see
what the return is on whatever you're selling
pretty quickly because you're the one selling
it but in film you you do the advertising and
you're waiting six months to find out whether
Amazon anybody bought the film on Amazon
and then you're past really the period so that's
makes the whole business so hard because you
just don't the companies that dominate the
space in terms of where people buy movies
can can dictate the terms of how they account
even to the distributors so you're saying that
a filmmaker reasonably most contracts would say
every quarter you're getting a statement for two
years and then after that it's bi-annually and
then annually yeah okay so then if they have nine
years then toward the latter end of it they're
going to be getting yearly statements correct
and some it depends on the
distributor because some distributors
are more amenable to changing their basic
terms than others so it kind of depends but
some distributors will say well eventually
if we if we don't collect anything we're
not going to account so there's zero coming in
there's no reason to send you a piece of paper
that says zero came in sometimes we try to add
language that says you're going to counterbus
regardless because I want you to be accountable
per se so it can depend on the distributor.